ヒューマンエラーを減らす中世の立場があるんです
まあいくらか全部全体的に喋らなくちゃいけないんですけど
政治 仕事 社会ということを書いたんですけど
損得で物を判断することに間違いがあるんですよ
この世界で 政治世界 社会
会社 仕事をどこを見ても
いつでも損得 損得 それしか考えてないんです
そこが大きい問題ですよ
矛盾の 損得基準の行為は損という結果になるんです
だから損得で考えるんだから
世界は損のみ取ってるんです
何やっても人類が損するんです
何やっても苦しい 苦しみが増えるだけ
これおかしいんです 損得の考え方は
命を粗末にするんですよ
損得は成り立ちませんよ
生命が生きているんですよ
生きている上でいろんなことをやっているんです
そこはうまくできるかないかぐらいのことで十分なのに
どれぐらい儲かるか どれぐらい赤字になるかという
とんでもない あり得もない
存在もしない くだらないことしか頭にないんです
数字で計算 まあこれするとこれぐらい損するんだ
これだったらこれぐらい儲かるんだと
それやってる人間のことはまるっきり気にしない
だからこれはものすごいおかしい間違いなんですよ
人間が先にいて仕事をしているんです
仕事があって人間ではないんです
なのに平気でそれを言うんですよ
仕事があって人間だと
国があって国民であると
そこまで言うんですから
もうどうにも どう言えばいいんでしょうかね
例えば子供にでも言ってみたらね
もうあの私はね 隣のおばさんがね
結婚してすぐ子供が生まれたんだから
あの子供と一緒に遊んであっちこっち行くんだから
自分にも立場がないんだからね
あなたを産んだんだよと
隣のおばさんと一緒に同じレベルになるために
すると向こうは幼稚園に子供
自分がいっぱいおしゃれして幼稚園に子供を連れて行くでしょう
だから私もちゃんとおしゃれして出かける理由がなくなるんだよと
子供がいなかったら だからあなたを産んだんだよと言っちゃうとどうなるんですかね
どれほどひどいことですかね
子供にそんなこと言うと
そういうことを世界は堂々と言っていますよ
会社があって あなた方だよと
会社は先やと 国がある
あって それから国民だよと
国のこと先やと 美しい文章でしょう
Do not ask what the country is doing for you. Ask w
hat you you are doing for
だかなんとかという あの
誰でしたっけ？あれ言ったのは
あの ケネディさんですね
で 国はあなたに何してくれるのかではなくて
あなたは国に対して何をしてくれるのかということを考えてくださいと
ああいうのはね ものすごい上手な作家が書くんですよ
一流の作家たちが だから言葉としては残りますよ
すごいぴったしの言葉で中身あるのかと
そういうことで 世界は命は全然気にしない
粗末 だからアメリカの若者はいくら死んでも大丈夫で
イラクで勝てば だからテロをね
自爆テロとかやってるでしょうに
その美しい すごい元気のもう見る限りえらい可愛いんですよ
その若者たちが行って
爆弾体に付けて殺すで死ぬでしょう
それはもう構いません
それよりはその人ほどの主義が大事です
だから命を大事にしないのはパレスチナのテロたちだけじゃなくて
イラクのテロたちだけじゃないんですよ
日本も同じことですよ
もうテロリストの国です
もうあなた方はどうなってもいいんです
会社だけ儲ければ儲ければ
テロリストの国々と何が違いますかね
だからこの命を粗末にするんだから大変な問題が起きてはいるんです
幸福に生きるという目的を基準にするならば
社会での失敗の問題は解決する
だからみんな 人間一人一人が幸福に
気楽に 楽しく生きるんだよ
それが目的だと だから幸福になるために頑張りましょうと
幸福にならないことをすぐたちまちやめましょうと
いう生き方であるはずですが
逆なんです あんた苦しんだって知ったもんじゃないんだよと
会社の仕事をしろよと言うと
誰にもいい仕事はできないし
幸福にはなりません 今と全く違った生き方が現れるんですよ
仏教的に生命を尊重する人間であるならばね
世界変わりますよ 昨日かな
あのクルド系の男性とフィリピンの女性と結婚して
日本で子供もいて もう強制退去だったっけ
裁判でまあ強制的に国から追い出すんですね
まあ訴えたはそれに反対して訴えたんですけど
これはもう法律的であると
そうするとお母さんがフィリピンに行かなくちゃいけない
で 男がイラクかどこかに行かなくちゃいけない
子供はどこにいるんでしょうか
行くでしょうかね アメリカだったら
もうアメリカで生まれたら
その子供にはアメリカ国籍
だからまあ人間じゃないんだから法律はない
法律はどうでもいいでしょうに
だから法律は人間のために作ったんじゃなくて
人間が法律のために生きてなくちゃいけないということですよ
で 一人一人日本人に個人的に言ったら
あなたはあの家族はそんな風にひどい目に遭って
それからどうすることもできなくて
不幸になって死ぬことは好きでしょうかと
そう言うと いい とんでもない
もう本当に幸せでいてほしいとかね
あれほど日本語も喋れて
こんな日本を好きな人だから
もう真面目に仕事をしているんだからいた方がいいんじゃないか
個人ではそう思うんだけど
では国は認めません だから裁判官にもどうすることもできないし
訴えたのは この退去命令は違法であると
違法ではありませんと
では この人権とか 何といいますか
人道的という言葉は通じないんですね
で あの日本人と結婚し
フィリピンから来て 日本人がすぐ離婚せたら出て行け
出て行けと言うんですね
奥さんに だからなんか変でしょ？どう考えても
なんでそういう変なこと起きるんですかね
結局は人命はどうでもいい
決まり守ることは大事やと
何のために決まるですかね
法律破ってでも人を助ければかっこいいのに
あるいは法律でそういうところは問題あるんだから
わざと新しく法律作ろうと
それでもう一つケースがあるでしょ
誰かがこの代理母で子供生まれて
日本ではその子供に生きる権利がないんです
この子供 2人に では  DNA では明らかにこの女の人の子供だと
それは認めませんよと
だから事実さえも認めない法律なんです
だから科学が発展しているんだから
代理母で産めるっていうことぐらいは
裁判官知ってるで それぐらいのことは
そこまではアホじゃないと思いますけど
まあアホには決まってますけど
そこまではないと思います
しかし それがなかなかこのシステムの中で機能しないんですよ
だからその場合は裁判が
それはまあ法律の問題であると言っていても
やっぱり最高裁判所には自分の国だったら法律変える権利があるんですよ
国は法律決めてなくても
自分が判決を出す こういうことにしますよと
するともうどうしようもなく
それが法律になるんです
これ 先例とか何とかいうのはそういうものなんです
だからまあ我々生きている世界っていうのは
そういう もうどこを見ても
やっぱり人間の命はもう全くもう 0 価値で
会社が一番大事で 金儲けることは何よりも大事で
もう実験することは何よりも大事で
周りの人々はどうなってもいいという
世界がものすごい反対しなかったら
アメリカがあっちこっちでビキニ島とか何とかところでね
原発をいろんなことをやって
日本人もやられたでしょうに
平気でやります そこら辺のもう放射能で漁しに行った人々は
みんなもう放射能浴びて自爆して
みんな認めない 認めない
認めないということで
世界が大騒ぎしたんだから
やっとそこはまあ日本人でも被害者はいるんだということになりましたけど
でなきゃ日本の政府もそんなことは認めませんということになるんです
そういうことで いろんなところで原子爆弾をもう何て言います
爆破してみて実験するとかね
海の中でやってみるとか
平気でやりたい放題やる
それで自然もそんなのは認めませんよと
軍隊ではずっと劣化ウランの爆弾で
もうもう弾で もうずっと人を殺したり殺したり
だから至る所で放射能で認めませんと
それで終わりです 大量にタミフルを買ったんだから
先取りということで 他の国々は買う前にこちら買ってやると
あの鳥インフルエンザが広げるという恐れがありましたからね
でも実際 タミフルを飲んじゃうと子供は飛び降りするんだからね
それは認めません そんなこと認めちゃったら
買ったものはどうするんですかね
子供 10人  20人ぐらい死んじゃってもね
買ったタミフルはそのまま処分しちゃうと
あの会社が損するでしょう
そこが大事なんです それだからって
そういう人々は恐ろしいというわけじゃないんですよね
そうなっているんです
別に政府の方々は残酷な人間というわけじゃないんです
困ったな これはまずいな
だから解散もやらなきゃと
自分での入ってくる政治献金もね
もあるしねということでね
だからまあもう気をつけてください
薬あげる場合はって その程度で終わっちゃうんです
そこである薬は先取りして買っちゃうし
ある薬は絶対認めないし
特にがん治療に普通の抗がん剤効かないっていうことがありまして
また実験的にはものすごく効くいろんな抗がん剤
薬があるみたい 日本では使用禁止
である人が精神安定剤やと言って頭イカれる薬もらっていて
いろんな私に言うのは
あんたどんな薬飲んでいるのかと
教えてくれと言っちゃうと
もうカタカナの名前で言ったんですけど
わからない それでカタカナから苦労して苦労してローマ字の名前を思い作って検索してみれば
使用禁止っていう風に出てきたんです
アメリカ イギリスサイトで調べたんですから
まあ昔使ってたんですけど
精神病気のこういう行為は今使用禁止
こちらでは一番最新の薬として
これは最新の薬だと言ってくれてるんだっていうことなんです
そんなもんですよ だからあるものは禁止する
例えばもう末期がんの人々に実験中の薬をあげたって
何も悪くないでしょうに
なぜならば その人々は喜んでそれを使ってますから
患者さんの方が 患者さんが末期癌だ
末期だから薬効いたらもう儲かったもので
効かなかったら それでも自分の自分が実験台になっていて
次の薬開発に貢献しているんですから
それまた儲かったもんで
どちらにせいても 患者さんにとってはいいことで
で 泣きながら訴えてたんですよ
ニュース見たら ある人はこういう我々には時間がないんだよと
政府はこの薬を認定するためには 15年かかるんだよと
しかし 私たちには時間がないんだと
1 日 1 日もうずっとの勢いで死にかけてますよと
だから何でしょうかね
人類は生きたりも輸入する
なんでそうなるんでしょうかね
いわゆる全体的な思考の問題なんですよ
ものが命より大事という
儲かることは命より大事ですよ
それは基本的に世の中どこにでもあります
だからしっかりと言わなきゃ
いかに俗世間の生き方
いかに残酷で恐ろしいかということは感じないんですよ
だから私はあえてそういうことを言うんで
言わなくたってもいいんですけど
今日は だから我々はなんのことなく
ニコニコと毎日やっている生き方があまりにも残酷で
良くないんですよ 本当にすっごい幸福な生き方があるんです
生きることが大 もうそれが唯一優先でしょうに
他のことはもう生きているんだからでしょうに
大事かないかっていうのは
人間生きてなかったら IT もいらんし
インターネットも要りませんし
新幹線も要りませんし
飛行機も何も要りませんでしょうに
人間がいるんだからでしょう
そちらに価値があるのは
これどうやって逆さまにしたんですかね
だから仏教的なところになってくると
そういうことになります
生きることはもっと大事にしろよと
ですから 仏教から言えば
失敗をなくすとは倫理ですよ
間違い 失敗 エラーなどは人間に生命に起こるものです
自然の変化 例えば山火事
地震 噴火 乾季 洪水 そのそれらは間違いでも失敗でもエラーでもないんです
そんなのは自然の変化だから
そんなことを気にする必要はないんです
誰が間違ったわけでもなく
神の怒りでも何でもないんです
人間は 生命は幸福に生きたいと希望する
苦を避けたいと苦労するんですよ
しかし 人間は生命は違います
生命は幸福に生きたいんですよ
苦労を避けたいんですよ
生きる意義は苦を避けることにあります
生きるということの意義は
苦を避けるというところにあるものなんです
これ 論理は立証するまでちょこっと長いんですから
次のページに行きます
幸福を目指さないならば
何もしなくても苦労して早死になるんです
もし生命は いえ 私は幸福は目指せませんだったら
そのままいればいいんです
何もしないですぐ死にます
生きる意味もないし 努力する必要もないんです
幸福を目指さないものには生きる意味もないし
努力する必要もない どこかで座り込んでじーっとしてればいいんです
死ぬまで ご飯さえ食べる必要はないんです
ご飯ちょこっと食べることでも幸福になりたいんだからなんです
苦しくなりたくないんだからなんです
ということで 間違い失敗エラーの管理は
人間の幸福な生き方を目的にするべきであることは必然的に成り立つんです
わかるかわからないか
私はわかりませんだけど
それはもっと軽くは言いたくもないんですけど
難しい論理なんです 一応軽々く言うんですけど
エラーをなくすことは必然的なになりたることなんです
わざわざ言わなくても
道徳なんです なぜならば
エラーをすると不幸になるんですよ
不幸になりたくないんです
生命は 不幸になりたい人々は
ご飯も食わないでどこかでしゃがみこんでいればいいんです
1日 2日で死にます 他の生命はみんな幸福になりたいんです
だから努力する 頑張る
それ努力すると頑張ると失敗っていうものが起きるんです
だから山火事は失敗と見做してはいけません
噴火は あ 私の人生は失敗だと
隣の山が噴火したんだから
何考えてるんです それは自然現象です
だから人間 生命がやっていることで失敗が起こる
失敗が起きちゃうと幸福がなくなっちゃう
だから幸福を目指すことが大事であって
避けられないことであって
幸福を目指すためには失敗を避けなくちゃいけないんです
ですから 生きることイコール幸福を目指すこと
したがって生きることっていうのは失敗を避けることになるんです
もう切り離せません ですから
失敗の管理は必然的に成立するものなんです
いわゆる生き方そのものなんです
だから 生き方はどのように生きるべきかということは道徳論なんです
科学ではないんです だから倫理なんです
幸福を目指す生き方が道徳的倫理的な生き方なので
失敗をなくすことは倫理でなくてはならないんです
だから 失敗しない生き方っていうのは倫理そのものなんです
会社であろうが 学校であろうか
病院であろうか 関係なく
失敗しない生き方が倫理なんです
今日の講演で初めて発表する論理はこれだけ
です 会社がもう儲けだけ
利益だけを目的にしてエラーの管理するならば
それは非道徳的なのです
もし会社が儲けだけを考えているならば
その会社が道徳を犯している倫理を犯している会社なんです
会社なんかあってもなくてもどうでもいいんです
人が幸福に生きることは大事なんですよ
幸福に生きるために会社が会社が必要になっただけです
その会社がもう儲けだけを考えているならば
恐ろしい非道徳的な倫理を破っている組合なんです
したがって 危機管理が危険を呼び寄せる結果になっているのは当然な結果なんですよ
だから会社の危機管理は危機を呼び寄せるんです
なお新しい危機を だってそれが悪行為だから悪結果になるんです
お釈迦様の教えでは 原因結果
悪因悪果 善因善果 だから確実に悪因だから悪果になるんです
会社が儲けるだけ考えちゃうと
儲かりませんし 社員たちが精神的にストレスたまったり
嫌な気持ちになって仕事を辞めたりもする
休んでくれませんだから休ませてくれませんだからね
病気になっても 儲かるつもりですけど
結局 2 3年仕事をして仕事を慣れた人はちょっと 2 日間休み休みくださいませんかって言ったら
そんなこと言ったら会社が困りますよと
で その人も病気だからもう会社辞めなくちゃいけないんです
そうすると新しい人をまた雇わなくちゃいけない
仕事はできない それでもう給料払わなくちゃいけないんだけど
仕事はまだまだ慣れてないんだから
それ損でしょうに あの人に 2 日間休んで休まっちゃった方がそれがないでしょうに
逆に 2 日間じゃなくて
あんた 3 日間いてしっかり治してよと
それはもっと大事だよと
会社よりはと いうて その人は 2 日間でもう仕事休みを取って
もっと会社のことを愛して心配して
これはもうすごい私が守ってあげなくちゃいけないものやと思って
もっと頑張ってくれるのに
それはもう考えたこともないんですね
だからこの儲けだけを考える危機管理は
結局は危機だけを呼び寄せる
それも因果法則で悪因悪果っていうのはもう定めですからね
どうしようもないんです
エラーをなくすように努力する個人が怯えているんです
だから一人一人個人がエラーをないようにと
間違いないようにと一生懸命だから怯えてるんですよ
ちょこっとでも失敗したら僕はガンガン言うんだから
弁償しなさいまで言うんだから
非難ばつに怯えているのです
能力の減退 予測外の失敗
苦しみが増す生き方が結果なんです
そういうことです 倫理破っちゃうと
だから怯えて危機管理すると能力が減退する
予測外のことは起こるんです
苦しみがさらに増えるんです
なくそうと思った苦しみがさらに増やす
世俗的な利益だけを目的にしているから
このような結果になるんです
もしエラーをなくすことは道徳であるならば
結果は幸福に変わるんです
エラーをなくすということは道徳だよと
倫理だよと エラーなくしちゃうと人々は幸せになるんだよと
生命が幸福になるんだよと
エラーがあると危険で
人の命は危ないんだよと
ということにすれば みんな喜んでエラーをなくすんですよ
怯えることなくなっちゃうんです
自分の他人の幸福のために
人類生命のために 自分が厳密にエラーチェックをしているから
やりがいが現れてくる
仏教的な入れ替え 入れ替えると
もうエラーチェックはやりがいあるんですよ
エラー間違いがあったら人には不幸ですよと
みんな大変なことになるんだよと
会社の社長に怒られると
どうでもいいんです そんなのは
会社が存続するかどうか
それは関係なく エラーしちゃうと生命は危険になりますから
だから自分が生命を守っているんですよ
生命を守るため 生命の幸福のために厳密にエラーチェックをする
そうするとすごいやりがい
意義が生じる 仕事に 生きることに
ストレスがなくなる 明るくなる
能力が向上する 同じことを前エラーをなくそうと思っちゃうと
矛盾で矛盾で矛盾で悪循環になるでしょうね
ちょこっと仏教的に見て
エラーをなくすことは道徳だよとわかったら
全く善循環に変わるんです
全く真逆に変わるんです
失敗をしないとは慈しみです
ですから 不完全な人間は間違いを少なくすることは心を清らかにする善行為です
そこと心は理性に帰れば
いかに世の中ちょっとしたことで変わるのかと
この鬼たちの世界は瞬間ですごい幸福な世界に変えられます
ブッダの言葉に耳を傾けば
そういうことで この何でしたっけ？不完全な人間だから間違いはする
それで間違いを少なくする
それだけ そこと昨日よりは間違いない生き方を今日やってみる
それだけのことが心を清らかにする行為であって
善行為なんです 善行為だったら善果なんですよ
因果法則はしっかり機能しています
だから長年食品を仕入れて会社でもちょっとしたことで 1日2日で倒産しますよ
最近スーパー誰でしたっけ？森永じゃなくて不二家
しかし 俗世間はいつでも欲と怒りで目がくらんでいるんです
原発の部品を提供する会社が微妙に規格を下げるんでしょ
金儲かるために 建築が鉄骨の数も減らすでしょ
食品会社が賞味期限が過ぎたものでも使用するでしょうに
工業会社が部品に欠陥があってもそれを認めないでしょうに
天下り談合ができるようにしているでしょうね
日本の政府は しかし 心配は無用です
お詫びさえすればね 万事解決
あんなのがあったっても
全然気にしないでください
原発事故があっても臨界事故があっても
まあもう隠しちゃえばもう誰もわからないしね
隠しちゃえば日本の技術は世界一でいいば
で バレたらお詫びする
そんなに楽な生き方あるんですかね
また しかし 徹底的に責めない限りは言い訳ばかりをして逃げ回るんです
失敗する人々を徹底的に周りが捕まって情報を取って
裏で何か密告でもしてもらったりして
なんとかデータ情報を漏らしてきて
責めたところで本当に申し訳ございませんでしたと
その人がかっこつけてお詫びすること
国政府が失敗しても それは国民のせいにする
政府はいつでも政府の失敗は国民のせいにするんです
社長の失敗に社員が背負うが
社長に失敗しないようにアドバイスすることは禁止
社長が失敗すると社員がそれを背負わなくちゃいけないんですよ
それで社員たちがあんなことをやったっても
社長 これダメ それは言ってはいけないんです
社長は偉い 黙っていなくちゃいけない
他人に指 他人に指を向ける世界は極まりなく危険ですよ
とにかく今のリストを見ると
みんな他人に指を指すだけ
あなたが悪いと このあなたが悪いという世界はもう極まりなく危険な世界なんです
微塵も良いところはないんです
はい 次に行きます 次はポイントを全く変えます
社会か個人かという 当然
社会 国 会社 学校などの団体の責任になる場合があります
例えば 失敗はもう学校の失敗
国の失敗というのは当然ありますよ
会社の失敗とかね しかし
団体の失敗は誰が直すのかとは問題です
だから学校が失敗したら
それが誰ですかね 直すのは
そこはよく考えなくちゃいけないんですよ
だって一人で いや 私は学校ではない
私はただの教師ですと
私は学校じゃない 私はただの校長ですとか
教頭なんて言ったってわからない
団体とは観念的な概念で
実は個人の集まりなんですよ
団体団体と言ったって
結局は個人の集まりでしょ
結局は個人が自分を戒めることしか他の選択はないんです
だから実際にいるのは個人
個人 個人 個人 個人 個人なんですよ
だから個人 個人 一人 自分を戒める
それしか道がないんです
団体に説教したっても
誰も聞いてないんです
団体は存在しないんだから
例えば団体に怒鳴ると
団体の一人だけ まあ俺は関係ないんだけどね
他の連中がやってることだから
堂々と聞いていられますよ
ある学校に来たこと悪口言ったても
その同じ学校の職員さんがね
まあそういえばそうですね
あの連中はね やっぱり
といって自分がそうじゃないということはいくらでもできますから
だから結局はこの世の中で個人
個人 個人しか生きていないんです
だから個人が自分を戒めるということになるんです
ですから 社会か個人かといえば個人なんです
そういうわけで 個人論というものが出てくるんです
ブッダは集団に対して規則を語るが
道徳は語らない 団体には
まあこういう風に仲良くしなさい
互いに喧嘩するなよ 調和を守り試しなさい
決まり守りなさいと そういうことで終わっちゃうんです
こういう風にして解脱に達しますよとか
このようにしたら天国に生まれますよ
全然言いません 団体にそんなこと言ったって意味がないんです
道徳は個人が守るものです
だから道徳っていうのは生き方です
嘘をつくなかれだけじゃなくて
完璧なすべての生き方は道徳なんです
ですから それは個人に語るんです
ブッダはあなた個人に
私個人に語るんです 経典を読んでみると
私個人に直接話しかけているんです
いつでも 皆様よ 人間たちよとは語ってないんです
あなたどう思いますか？という感じなんです
個人が道徳を守るなら
社会が損する危険 失敗
エラーを 危険な失敗 エラーが消えるんです
個人が道徳を守るということは
エラーがないということでしょう
だって エラーをなくすことは道徳ですからね
個人が道徳を守るんだったら
全部たちまち世界からエラー失敗は消えます
次のポイント わがままは通らないということ
これを覚えたい方がいいんです
人間には自由がないんです
果物の中に 1個だけでも腐ったものがあると
全体的に腐るんです 食べ物の中に一つだけでも汚染されたものがある時
食べ物はすべてが汚染してしまうんです
一つ悪くなったら大丈夫です
全部終わり 食べられないんです
社会では一人のわがままが社会全体に悪影響を与えるんです
仕事をサボる サボる 勉強をサボる者は
全人類に対して悪行為をしているんです
遊びじゃないんです 勝手に何かサボっちゃったと言っても
悪行為です すごい悪行為なんです
その影響は全人類に及んでいくんです
したがって 私は嫌だからやめるは通らないんです
自分の他人の幸福のために生きるしか
他の選択はないんです
幸福 嫌だったらどこかでしゃがみ込んでそのままいればいいんです
学校をやめてあっちこっち遊びに行くんじゃないんです
ゲームセンターやらいろんなところで
それは幸福を欲しということでしょうに
幸福が欲しければ その法則を守らないと
そういうわけで 美人でも理性のある頭の美人でもわかる
物事わかるね  2 たす 2 は 4 4
だよぐらいわかる人間ならね
選択ないってこと知ってます
自分には その幸福の道を歩むしか選択はないんだろうと
わがままは通らないんです
しかし みんなわがままで生きてるでしょう
だからものすごい罪なんです
重罪なんでしょ 小さな罪じゃないんです
悪行為自体が法則違反です
だから学校をサボることは法則違反で悪行為です
一人で怠けることさえも法則違反です
私はもう怠けたいんだから怠けてやるぞと
本人怠けるとどれぐらいの自分生きている社会に関係あるかと
すごいでしょう だから一人で怠けたいんだからって怠けられるはずがないんです
法則違反です 一人一人が自分の責任を果たし
幸福を目指して生きることが唯一の道なんです
だから 人のわがままは全然通らないんです
真理の世界では 真理を知っているならば
真理というのは地球が丸いというようなことで
これはどうにもならん
誰に文句を言ったって意味がないんです
道徳的な生き方っていうのは
まあ好きだったらやってくださいって選択ないんです
呼吸と同じ 肉体を持っているならば呼吸しなくちゃいけない
もう選択はないんです
だから仏教だけ道徳はしっかり成立しているんです
生きてるものは呼吸するのをごとく
道徳を守るべきであると思って
一人一人が自分の行為の失敗を
極力 極力減らさなくてはならないんです
だから一人一人が失敗します
それはいいんです 別に
それを減らすんです これが法則であることは
ブッダが無知な人に語り続けているんです
これこそが法則だよと
こんな無知な人々にずっと語り続けているんです
神の定めではありません
こんなの一つ 例えば 人が不完全であって
いろいろ それは神が神の怒りでもなんでもないんです
エラーチェックをして生きることは自然な生き方なんです
それこそ自然なんです
エラーチェック嫌だとか
仕事に行きに嫌だというのは
それが不自然なんです
人を助けるのは嫌だとかね
それが不自然です ですから
自然な生き方をする人は
とても穏やかで明るく活発に生きる方法なのです
だから同じエラーチェックは最大の危険を招くものなんですけど
それが仏教的にエラーチェックすると最大の幸福になる自然な流れになるんです
決して変な不自然なものにはなりません
あ やっぱりわがまま通る場合もあります
決して通らないというか
本当は全然自由がないんです
わがまま通る場合もあります
もし自分を向上させたい
惨めな思いをしたくない
無知は嫌だ 汚れた心は嫌だ
未熟な人格は嫌だ 苦しみは嫌だと思うなら
それは相当なわがままなんです
思うのないんだからね
本当は 負けず嫌いで失敗はしたくないならわがままですよ
かなり質の悪いわがままなんですよ
しかし このわがままは素晴らしいんです
この人に自分が好きなように生きることができるんです
だから わがままで言ったっても
こんなわがままじゃないでしょ
もっと気持ち悪い臭いわがままでしょ
人間はわがままだったら
これも相当わがままですよ
そんなこと言ったっても
人間は人間だからね しかし
こういうわがままを持ってる人は
自分好きなように生きてればいいんです
そうするとどんどん向上していくんです
だって 巻き添えくらいのわがままだったら
好きなようにやらせば巻き添えだから
もうもう失敗しないでしょうに
だから この場合に限ってわがままは通じる
通じるんです 感情と思考を持つ生命は必ず失敗する
すぐ早く終わりたいんで
まだまだ たくさんあります
また エラーの原因はもう一度読みます
もう一度  2番目 前とちょっと違うことです
で 人の理解能力が決して足りません
人間の理解能力っていうのは未熟ですよ
日々勉強で経験で深めるものなので
いつたっても不完全ですよ
我々の理解能力っていうのは
どんどんどんどん日々勉強して経験して深めるものだから
いつだっても不完全です
感情があるから 物事を感情の色眼鏡で見てしまう
それを上で理解は足りませんし
それではひどいなのに感情とやりますね
感情があると物を見ない感情で見るんです
それで主観的になって
理性と客観性を失ってしまうんですね
生の人間なので 力に波があるんです
機械ではありません 人間は
今日は 4キロ歩いたんだから
じゃあ明日も 4キロ これはわかりませんよ
生の人間だから そういうことで波があります
そこはもうそれが失敗の理性
理解足らないことと感情が割り込むことと
人生に波があること この 3つなんです
この 3つを覚えてください
この 3つで失敗するんです
気づきとエラーチェック
エラーチェックは慈しみの行為であること
善行為であることを理解する
まずそれを理解しておきましょう
エラーのない人生 エラーのない仕事っていうのは慈しみの行為なんです
善行為なんです すべてが不完全なので
エラーチェックをしない限り
見事にうまくいった 大成功だという結果にはなりません
これも知っておく 自分がしっかりとエラーチェックしないと失敗に決まっている
なぜなら不完全だから
自分の行為も不完全 物事も不完全
それを組み合わせたら不完全な結果で失敗ですよ
だからエラーチェックをしなくちゃいけない
ですから 見事にいった見事にいったってことは成り立ちません
いつでもエラーチェックしない限りは
えーと いかなることでも秒単位で行うんですよ
人間が仕事は秒単位でやっています
今の 1 秒で行うことは失敗しないようにする
ですから 大胆なことは要りません
今の 1 秒の仕事は失敗しないようにとすればいいんです 1
秒の仕事に 30 秒取っちゃうと失敗です
だから 1 秒の仕事は成功させる
それで長い話は終わります
こんな長く喋らなくたっても
これだけで答えですよ
できないというならば
そうといて頭が悪いということしか言いようもないんで
1 秒に気づける人に集中力が現れるんです
伴って充実感 幸福感が生じるんです
理解能力は向上するんです
心の汚れも感情も減るんです
たった 1 秒だけに仕事をすると
人格は完成を目指して上昇するんです
成功し続ける生き方になるんです
失敗のない いつでも成功
成功 成功 成功者が解脱に達するんです
あえて特別な修行の道ということじゃなくて
ごく普通に生き方がそのように解脱まで入れ替えることはできます
やり方はすごいシンプル
1 秒に気をつける  1 秒を生きる
今を生きる 今の瞬間を生きるという
たったそれだけのことなんです
はい まあ最後のタイトルだと思います
矛盾が成り立たない仏教では
仏教的なエラーチェックでは損はないんです
これ最初の言葉と同じ
強烈的な反対立的です
最初ってのはエラーチェックすることですごい損するんだよ
矛盾だよと しかし 仏教的にすりみればそれは治りなくなります
仏教の道は向上への高速道路です
エラーチェックは自分の心のチェックです
他人との戦いではありません
仕事の邪魔になる行為になりません
エラーチェック 例えばエラーチェックばっかりしちゃうと
時々いろいろ飛行機でもたまたまなかなか離陸しない
もうエラーチェックしています
随分遅くて あれやこれやとか
だからそういう風に本当のエラーチェックというのは仕事の邪魔になりません
俗世間がやっているエラーチェックのような悪循環ではありません
仏教的なエラーチェックというのは悪循環にもなりません
知識があってもなくても
誰にでも実行できる生き方なんです
間違いない生き方というのは
この知識いらん 誰にでも 1 秒の生き方はできます
はい 最後かな チェックポイント
で 我々はどういうところをチェックするかというと
だいたい 8 項目は書いてあります
慈しみが心にあるか否か
妄想で心が混乱しているか否か
それは常態をなくしたいんですね
それから 欲 怒り 無知 見などの感情が心に今の瞬間にあるか否か
だからこの感情ある瞬間で失敗しますから
気をつけなくちゃ その時仕事を辞めるか
感情をなくすかどちらかなんです
まあ永久的だ 私はやっぱり怒りあります
よくありますからと言ったら
もうもう見込みがなくなりますから
これはありますよ だから今の瞬間でなければいいんです
わがままになっているか否か
わがままになっているならば
もうダメ もうアウト もう失敗
だから心チェックするんだ
わがままか否かとか 怠けが入って手抜く投げやり気分になっているか否か
怠けが入っちゃうと もうすぐ手抜くになっちゃうし
投げやりでもやっちゃうということもありますから
今怠けが入ってるかないか
今の一秒でそれをチェックするんです
今の瞬間の仕事が楽しく感じているか否か
この 1 秒間の仕事は楽しいかと
そんなたくさんチェックできないと思うでしょう
できますよ なぜかというと
全部いっぺんには出てこないんです
心に怒りがあると怠けがないんです
怠けが入っちゃうと ただ怠けだけでもう怒る元気もないんです
だからこう あっても簡単で
チェックは 体の調子は良いか悪いか
肉体で生きてなくちゃダメだからね
これがロボットじゃないんだからね
いろいろ波があります
心の 心も生き物だからね
心の動きはスムースか否か
以上です これで完璧 完成
中 波が悪い時 仕事を休むか
別なことをして元気を取り戻すかしなくてはならないんです
波のチェックの場合は
これは自分ではどうすることも怒りは自分でなくせますけど
対象の体調が悪いということは
もう自分にとってはどうすることもできないんだから
その時は別なことを何とかして体調を取り戻すか
あるいは取り戻せないならば休むということになるんです
仕事を休むことでは失敗しないで済むんです
終わりです そういう8項目で全て完了します